the part that I enjoy most about uh C4
meetings is that it brings together a
very diverse um set of experts and you
really need this to map the human body
across
scales having a range of expertise
around the room to to talk about this
challenging problem that is incredible
you know intense discussion over two
days to find a way forward and you can't
solve this without that
interdisciplinary
approach this multiscale model has been
the holy glad of the system biology
since its Inception 25 years ago and I
think time is right you know we have a
better technology we have better
understanding how to go about it so this
is really a Grand Challenge or the
moonshot for biomedical science if
you're able to um accomplish mapping the
human body across scales then what might
be possible is to have a digital twin of
you so when you are born this algorithm
would start running and as data sets
become available you could run any kind
of predictions of what might happen over
your lifetime in that model and I think
it will help us understand why certain
diseases happen and how to treat them
better or even recognize them before
they start and so I look forward to more
Precision Health less Precision medicine
we are on the very early stage of yet
another Industrial Revolution in next 5
years we're going to see the dramatic
change in the way we do science and I
think this CA McMillan multiscale human
project can be really the Showcase
embracing a new technology because you
need the technology to achieve the
science I think I'm just grateful that
you know CA and McMillan see this
challenge as being fundamentally
important in in terms of where we go
next in mapping the human body to really
make that transformative Next Step the
radical change that's needed to improve
human
[Music]
life